piggybacking off of the excellent nbc
coverage the dramatic and controversial
finish hey let's turn it into something
we can use a draft a draft of the most
controversial finishes in nfl history
and in doing my research last night i'm
amazed how many there are how do you
narrow it down to three each we're gonna
find out and now is the time when you
get to call tails and it's gonna be
tails it's more rigged than than the
kentucky derby was although the kentucky
debris was and i just said that go ahead
and call tails
tails
it was heads
it was heads on thursday and i called
them how it works
i i just i know my girl kristen because
you cracked the code
you're like the guy on jeopardy man
you've cracked the code yeah go ahead i
i know when she's feeling sorry for you
just enough to when that's when i need
to call ahead so okay here we go um i i
think this one is
this is actually it's a hard first pick
here um i'm going to go with the tuck
rule as the most controversial ending to
a football game yeah i'm going to go
there what more because you took the
that's the obvious one there's nothing
hard about it that's the obvious one
well there's the one that just happened
this year that's pretty obvious too
maybe more obvious i mean and that's
where you're gonna go next so to blow
everybo to blow your pick away right
there i went with the better one so here
we go but the tuck rule i mean none of
us have really ever known of it or knew
what the rule meant or how it existed
and of course here we are in the uh 2001
afc divisional playoff game the snow
game adam vinitari's famous kick and all
of that gosh the oakland raiders are
winning a football game and tom brady
the new england patriots are moving down
the field and up to that point we had
seen nothing but tom brady be clutch and
every moment that he was asked of him
that year and all of a sudden his old
college buddy comes off the edge and
hits him as he is standing there slashed
maybe just you know pumped the ball but
of course that taught us all about what
the tuck rule was there and still to
live by the letter of the law the
referees got the call right but we just
had no knew nothing about it at the time
and to the naked eye and the viewer it
certainly looked like a throwing of the
or a fumble on the field to where the
raiders were covered and looked like the
game was going to be over but the tuck
rule comes about we know that vinatari
kicks the field goal to win it uh or tie
it then win it later on and then of
course starts the patriots dynasty run
so that's why it's not only a huge
controversial moment but it's set up the
greatest dynasty we've seen in the
history of the nfl to this point
i still think they'd be pretty good if
they hadn't won that game i still think
that tom brady and bill belichick would
have found a way to continue to win
games and win at a high level but you
know i like that pick because
it it reminds me of what happened on
saturday it was the correct application
of a rule that most people weren't aware
of now in the nfl was a very obscure
rule in horse racing it's just most
people aren't aware of the rules because
they only watch the triple crown races
but it's that same sense of what the
hell just happened and it turns out it
was accurate it turns out that it was
proper and it turns out the nfl quietly
got rid of the tuck rule about 12 years
later so it wouldn't be too conspicuous
that they realized yeah this is probably
not a good rule we probably should
change it so yeah to me that was the
obvious first pick i'm surprised it was
even close for you and you're right the
second pick and it happened so recently
i feel like there should be more of a
historical angle to it but i think this
is one we'll be talking about for
decades to come saints rams nfc
championship game more consequential
than yours because a birth in the super
bowl was on the line and to have tommy
lee lewis the saints receiver who i
think has since signed with the lions
get wiped out by nikkel roby coleman
roby coleman was so badly out of
position he ran across the field knowing
his only play was to wipe out tommy lee
lewis he fully expected to be penalized
and he wasn't that was the stunner and
the more i see it the more astounded i
am that they didn't throw the flag they
blew it the saints would have had the
ball first and goal inside the five if
they score a touchdown it makes it much
more difficult for the rams to force
overtime the rams do force overtime they
win the game they move on and ultimately
lose the super bowl amid historic low
ratings in new orleans people just did
not want to watch that game and i can
understand why they didn't want to watch
it yeah i get it it was brutal i mean it
really was uh it stung for saints fam
fans and it stung it stunk for any nfl
fan altogether because it did it felt
like it tainted the super bowl a little
bit you know the rams had to answer all
these questions do you think you guys
really deserved to be here all of that
so i certainly didn't like that and then
added to the fact that the game was a
little bit of a dud i don't think
anybody would deny that as far as 13 to
3 and lacks you know lack sexy moments
or big moments in the football game to
where i think a lot of people look at
and go man i think the saints patriots
would have been a better super bowl or
maybe more exciting and i think that
adds to it too but uh i'm not mad
with with that pick that certainly makes
a lot of sense i'm gonna go to a similar
scenario okay i'm going to the nfc
championship game the 1990 season the
bird emanuel rule right uh almost it's
really the bird emmanuel rule here's the
tampa bay buccaneers the 1999 nfc
championship game they're in saint louis
they're playing the greatest show on
turf and kurt warner they're down 13-6
there's under a minute left in the game
they're driving down the field bert
emanuel catches a ball over the middle
of the field arms extended
n has control of the ball from get-go
never loses control
nothing but the ball hits the ground and
at the time
if the ball touched the ground it was
considered an incomplete pass and then
we know now that that rule has been
changed as long as you show that you
still have control of the football the
football can touch the ground well you
know this was the moment that changed
all of that and yes then it set up the
the rams to go on and kurt wanted to win
the mvp the super bowl uh against the
the tennessee titans and all of that but
that certainly is a moment that i will
never forget sitting there going wow the
greatest show on turf whoa they're
really struggling against this awesome
tampa bay buccaneers defense
and this quarterback i've never heard of
sean king who you know is he keeps
playing good you know at the time he
just wasn't a household name but played
clutch in some big moments at the end of
the year and of course was showing that
he was going to be clutch again and uh
the burden manual rule came back to
strike them in the butt well and here's
the thing now if you go back and watch
the bird emanuel play it it wasn't as
clean as i think we believe in hindsight
there was some movement of the ball but
it did spawn the rule change that
allowed the ball to touch the ground and
and that is what sparked years of
confusion and uncertainty about what the
hell a catch is so this is a controversy
that launched a thousand other
controversies over the course of the
last 20 years but you know at the time
it it was just hey that's the rule i
don't know that that was a controversial
finish because it was accepted so i'm
going to throw the challenge flag on you
for that one because no one said oh no
wait a minute what's going on here no it
it was the rule hey sorry rams that's
the rule i mean sorry bucks that's the
rule it's not a catch but it was the
rule change that created the controversy
so you're kind of in the wrong pew of
the right church on this because i don't
remember that outcome
being controversial it's just the nfl
decided to react to it by changing the
rule and i'm surprised they did in
hindsight because it's not like people
were losing their minds
about that rule i don't remember that
that all we have to change this rule i
was surprised they changed the rule i
like it chris that it's an incomplete
pass if the ball touches the ground i
mean that should be the litmus test if
the ball touches the ground it's not a
catch no i i don't agree with that you
know again when they're when you're
playing football and you have control of
the football and grown men are knocking
you all over the place there's a lot of
times you catch the ball and you're
going to take a catch away from a guy if
the point of the ball just scrapes the
ground even though he shows it's
securely in your hands that's what
happened there there was controversy
then people still talk about it so as
much as you want to try to downplay my
great second round pick it was good and
deal with it
in baseball if the ball touches the
ground is it a catch
i mean if we were talking about the same
sport i would answer an intelligent uh
dumb question like that but i'm not
going a good try
um i'm gonna go from that same round of
the playoffs the team that made it to
the super bowl that year the team made
the super bowl in part because it
managed to win a wild card game off of
what appeared to be a forward pass at
the time the music city miracle that was
something that there is still hard
feelings about wade phillips who was the
coach of the bills at the time not
pleased with the ruling and i remember
watching that live yeah where the the
at the time the replay review was done
on the field the booth was pressed up
against the the railing and you could
as the referee was in there you could
see all these titans fans clustered
around right above it like these guys
want to get out of here alive do you
really think they're going to overturn
that call and give the game to buffalo
heck no they ruled it as a lateral and
the touchdown throw from uh uh frank
wycheck to kevin dyson ended up counting
on that that last ditch kickoff return
and the titans would parlay that into a
super bowl appearance against the rams
who ultimately would win the game all
right we got to take a break chris we
got two rounds down when we return
round three of the most controversial
finishes in nfl history will do that
when pft live continues right after this
i didn't get a chance to rebuke that
pick
chris i didn't give you a chance to poo
poo my pick of the music city miracle
what can you say
bad about the controversy that was the
music
it's just you i want to argue against
okay there johnny lawyer okay johnny law
school because you argue about mine not
being that controversial and then you
pick a game where the guy legally
ladders the ball backwards no rule ever
gets changed or nothing ask what you're
going to do that's fine oh gosh if wade
said so then jeez okay
all right i just wanted to do that i
wanted to be a lawyer too like you okay
um all right so my third pick to win
this draft by a mile will be
the san francisco
49ers new york giants wild card game uh
with the 2000
right 2002 ceo i hear someone groaning
in my ear i think that was stats who
just said oh
yes well the 49ers made a magical
comeback they were down 38 to 14. they
come back to take the lead 39-38 against
the new york giants and kerry collins
and jeremy shockey well kerry collins
drives the team down the football field
to get in field goal position if you
remember it's kind of a botched snap on
the field goal the placeholders run
stands up runs around tells some guys to
go down the field for a pass he ends up
throwing a pass to a person that is
eligible receiver down the field clearly
blatant pass interference uh on the
on the intended receiver with the pass
from the placeholder and it was not
called because the referees weren't sure
if that was truly a legitimate downfield
legal target and they didn't know and
therefore the 49ers won the game where
really the giants should have been
granted penalty yards and another chance
to kick that field goal to win the
football game that was a huge moment i
think we forget about it sometimes
because it wasn't an nfc championship
game or anything like that but certainly
a pretty big deal
all right giants fanny you're done i'm
done
all right
uh yeah i that one was on my list but it
was way down you blew it you you allowed
your giants homerish tendencies
to to influence you when there were
plenty of other choices you could have
made you could have you could have gone
fail mary i'm not but you could have
gone fail mary you could have gone with
the holy roller from back in the 70s
which changed the rules about advancing
fumbles right you could have gone with
the snowplow game from 1982 when all
regulators had a guy on work release i'm
just saying
still better here's one that and this is
a regular season game but i am still
taking it because it fits with the
manner in which this rigged witch hunt
of a coin toss continues to be slanted
against me i have to go back to 1998 to
the thanksgiving day game the early game
the steelers at the lions when when phil
luckett got the coin toss wrong jerome
bettis either said heads or tails and
phil luckett said the other one and
insisted that bettis said what he didn't
say the lions won the toss went down the
field kicked a field goal won the game
and walked off the winners all because
phil luckett didn't hear jerome bettis
call the correct coin toss so that has
to be given that the coin toss
continuously screws me every time we do
one of these drafts it had to be in
there well
it is a great one i actually wanted to
pull it up and look at the video real
quick because
two if i remember correctly
like
what did jerome bettis kind of say both
am i wrong there or did he clearly say
one like am i am i off base here all the
way i just felt like i thought it was
i thought it was pretty clear he said
one but they changed the rule as a
result of it you now have to pick the
heads or tails
while the coin is in the palm right you
you choose before it used to be call it
in the air and that's what happens when
you call it in the air you can have that
moment of confusion and uh you know with
the the the coins in the air you have to
make a pretty quick decision then but it
was there was something weird where it
may not have been entirely clear but
luck it just should have done it again
if there's any doubt they should have
done it again i'm actually gonna listen
to it i'm sorry i got it pulled up here
i won the draft so there's no point
discussing that
and give me one all right you picked
you picked the tuck rule they were all
up there for a second now i got to check
him here the tuck rule
the bird emanuel game the 2002 the very
memorable giants 49ers 2002 wild card
game i've got the rams and the saints no
call the music city miracle and the uh
the coin toss in the thanksgiving day
game from 1998 between the steelers and
the lions so i i won i won this one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports